I want to talk a little bit about last
week's James Comey hearings what wasn't
said in those hearings is just as
important as what was said and the
meaning and the style of the non answers
from James Comey are both very relevant
5:38 did a sort of compilation of what
James Comey didn't answer during the
testimony why are not answer is
important well it's about not ruling
things out that would be way simpler for
James Comey to just say didn't happen no
and not saying no opens the door to
possibly really serious things and
there's examples of how not answering
something one way or the other is not
always the same if I say to NSA director
Admiral Mike Rogers during a hearing Pat
is Joe Smith a covert operative for
Admiral Mike Rogers to say I'm not going
to speak one way or another about that
that makes sense that is very different
than saying hey were you ever asked by
anyone at the White House to make false
statements I'm not going to comment
about my conversations with people at
the White House that's a very different
non answer than outing a CIA operative
so to speak those that difference of no
versus to the best of my knowledge no
yes and oftentimes the the wordsmithing
that exists is also relevant so let's
look at some of these items that James
Comey refused to talk about which are
very very relevant this is again from
538 website this is the communication
between the Trump and Russia campaign
Comey refused to discuss whether there
was a backdoor communication channel
established between Donald Trump and
Russia that's relevant because there
have been many allegations relating to
and involving many Trump staffers and
Jared Kushner's desire to establish this
backdoor channel Comey did not discuss
whether there were more undisclosed
meetings than the ones that have gone
public common sense tells us yes they
were because we continue hearing about
more and more undisclosed meeting James
Comey did not discuss whether there were
attempts to
conceal or destroy evidence of
communication between Donald Trump and
Russia very relevant to what is going on
James Comey also didn't discuss what he
knows about that VEB Russian bank whose
chief reportedly met with Jared Kushner
during the transition okay with regard
to Michael Flynn James Comey did not
talk about during last week's hearing he
did not say whether Michael Flynn is a
central figure that is relevant because
we know of so much that James Comey did
if Cole I'm sorry what about that
Michael Flynn did if Michael Flynn is
not a central figure
it almost tells us more about how bad
the situation is also from 5:38
assessment when it comes to questions
about Donald Trump James Comey refused
to talk about whether Donald Trump
colluded with the Russians okay that one
we can sort of understand but more
interestingly James Comey refused to
talk about whether any of the criminal
allegations in that now-infamous
blackmail dossier are true will we ever
get answers to those questions I'm not
really sure some claiming pat that we
can't read anything into James Comey is
not answers I don't agree with that
James Comey does not mince words as we
know he has been clear for example that
donald trump at two different moments
was not personally under investigation
so i think that while we can't
necessarily deduce anything specific
from commis not answers Comey is a guy
who speaks very clearly and forthrightly
when he feels he can I think this is
very important is it possible though
that James Comey just wasn't willing to
bring up a lot of the Trump Russia
collusion allegations because he didn't
really think it was fitting given that
special prosecutor Moeller has taken
over in that regard yes that is a
relevant question right which is if
Comey feels he's there to talk about a
he's just not going to talk about B this
is one of those cases where we have to
look at if there's something that is
potentially major and James Comey could
very easily just say nothing there folks
with a simple no
answer the fact that he chooses not to
do that is not meaningless and my advice
to Democrats would be follow every lead
through let Muller do his job but
simultaneously because as we're starting
to see this could be a really long haul
this could go beyond the 2018 midterms
progressives and Democrats have to build
a platform for 2018 Watergate and Nixon
as you pointed out Pat took a long time
this might lead to nothing it might lead
to something but we're halfway to 2018
here progressives have got to get a
platform together and we still did learn
a lot from this James Comey testimony
like for example he felt directed by
Donald Trump to end the investigation
into Michael Flint made and Comey called
Donald Trump a liar on more than one
occasion he said the entire I mean the
whole context of why these memos exist
that James Comey took contemporaneously
after these meetings it's because he
said unlike with all the other people
I've worked with
I believe Donald Trump was at some point
not going to tell the truth about this
that in and of itself is major so send
me your thoughts about the non answers
of James Comey I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show and I'm sure that we will be
following up about this today's episode
is sponsored by taga dab the hosting
specialists offering a great range of
affordable and flexible hosting packages
whether it's dedicated hosting virtual
private servers cloud server options
custom server solutions whatever you
need taga dab has it they're very proud
of their team of expert hosting
specialists who also happen to make up
their friendly support team and they
give their customers full access to both
their knowledge and service taga dab
currently have an average Trustpilot
review rating of excellent at nine point
seven out of ten with more and more
people interested in moving their
businesses and projects to the cloud
taga dab is offering a ten british pound
free credit to all new customers signing
up for cloud server solutions that's
about 12 or 13 US dollars to take
advantage of that go to sign up taga Deb
comm slash TDP
yes that is sign up ta ga da be calm /t
DPS